hi everyone you might have seen I've got
a couple of videos on my channel letter
things like my regrets studying physics
or my regrets studying math and in those
videos I don't talk about like
absolutely soul-crushing regrets of mine
but just things I wish I'd done
differently so today I'm joined by Jess
and Jess is an engineer that's what
she's studied and I guess we're gonna
ask her what some of her regrets are
along the way so jess what was your
degree and what did you study so I
studied I have a master's in mechanical
engineering and I have a bachelors in
like combined mechanical and
aeronautical engineering so from this
point like how do you feel about that
degree like I'm happy it's over as
anything strike you as maybe something
you would have done differently
you know I was thinking about it and at
first there's not like I don't have you
know something that's very striking like
oh like my entire life would be
different if I had done this one
different thing and that's that's
actually one of my points is that one
thing that I kind of regret that I did a
lot in school was I stressed a lot and
it kind of seems like a stupid regret
maybe like I don't know stressing isn't
that big of a deal but that's what I
mean like I don't really feel like I
regret so much but at the time I was
really stressed about things like I
didn't do well on an exam I would really
be hard on myself or not like punish
myself but then I would like miss a
party or something that I wanted to go
to those I'd be like no I have to study
super hard and in the end I mean I'm
here now and you could I guess argue I'm
here because I did all of that studying
but also I think a lot of those little
things that we worry about don't really
matter in
yeah like through all of the studies
I've done I have been you know quite a
maybe a stressed out person but someone
that does care about the details like
aiming for an unreasonably high mark
even though getting a lower ground being
happier would probably just have been
less stress around like and especially
looking back now it probably didn't like
oh it doesn't matter
what I am doing right now for myself
like on YouTube and all this it doesn't
matter at all yeah I I wouldn't say so
much was that I'd like to go back in and
for lower grades like I wouldn't say
that at all but I yeah I would probably
want to be less stressed as well because
I think even at the time in my degree I
I suspected it might not matter like I
suspect a better grade on this one
particular course war didn't stop me
from doing my dream job but I don't know
I did worry about it probably an
unreasonable amount yeah like for
example I actually I failed my very
first math quiz ever at my university
and I felt defeated because you you like
you're you're kind of like a smart nerd
in high school and then you get to like
a good university and then you start
doing well and then you take your first
class and then you get your first quiz
and I completely failed it because well
I mean it was kind of stupid it was
three questions and they just said write
the answer what kind of a math class
only wants to see your final answer that
that quiz didn't do anything for my GPA
didn't do anything in life I mean I
would take it and fail it again I've but
I did cause myself a lot of stress and
you know thankfully my family is in good
health but I think I did not like you
know stay in touch that well with my
family while I was studying and my
excuse was always like yeah I'm working
I'm studying in like they're super
supportive and understood but I kind of
wish I was
her granddaughter daughter and like
called more often and studied less all
right so that's that one have you got
any other sort of regrets yeah so I mean
I took a lot of really like I I was on
this path right I was on a path of like
studying combustion and that's all I
wanted to do and so I took like
turbomachinery I took you know
turbulence modeling and reactive flows
and combustion all of these different
like courses that were super heavy and
super focused on what I wanted to do
spoiler I don't do that anymore
but because I was taking all these heavy
courses I still had room in my schedule
because you have to take a certain
Americas and I ended up taking like not
like easy courses but kind of easier or
not that interesting or less demanding
courses because I just wanted to focus
on my important courses so for example I
took this class called carbon capture
and storage I mean no offense to that
class but it wasn't anything you
couldn't find out after like reading the
Wikipedia page and I kind of wish I took
you know there's this one class that we
have at ETH and it's like wind wind
energy and you have to end up doing it's
like a lot of fluid dynamics designing
the blades of the wind turbines to be
more efficient and stuff and I had
already taken kind of a class similar
because I had done like veins and rotors
and stators inside of gas turbine
engines so that's an internal flow the
wind turbine would be an external flow
so it's a different problem but yeah I
was kind of like oh I don't need to take
that class because I mean I've already
kind of done it
and I'm not interested in that either
and now I'm like working in energy and I
kind of wish I took something other than
combustion and I also wish I took
machine learning and I know you were
telling me something about you wanted to
take computer science classes yeah I
think one of the regrets I've mentioned
on my channel before is that I probably
wish I had taken more computer science
classes maybe early on because I only
took really a couple and because I
didn't know that they would be useful or
important because they weren't called
physics life and I was only worried
about physics I didn't realize at the
time that actually doing real physics
involves actually knowing a lot of
computers yes yeah and that's the thing
like I kind of wish I took machine
learning or other computer science
because it's useful in a lot of
different fields but also it's when
you're in school you have the time to
dedicate to these kind of like more
maybe difficult topics whereas now if I
wanted to learn machine learning I would
have to like really find the time
dedicate the time and like set the time
aside to actually you know learn the
material yeah I think it's harder to
live outside of uni but at the same time
like how could you have known at a time
that you didn't want to take that
combustion course hmm I I struggle with
us like how do you know exactly what
courses you want to take because I do
think you probably might end up doing
some completely different subject and
you didn't even take any of those
courses and that happens quite a lot how
do you know that beforehand like I don't
know I guess the only advice would be to
just take a bit of a variety of courses
so that at least you've covered the
basis of a few different things yeah
that's what I would do I would suggest
taking a variety of courses and yeah I
think my regret is though like taking
that carbon capture no like yeah like I
also had to take a humanities course and
I had taken what is science as my like
philosophy course when I could have
taken I don't know like history of math
or something really cool but instead I
didn't want to take a more demanding
class because I wanted to focus on my
master's thesis and on my harder courses
and then I have one more regret and
that's there have been times where I had
gone for an interview and it was kind of
like I wasn't really too worried like I
hadn't really prepared I don't really
know what the interview would entail and
I didn't really want the job but in
hindsight I kind of regret not and then
the interview ended up asking some like
actual technical questions which I
didn't prepare for and in hindsight I
kind of wish I had prepared more because
yeah you you it's just nice to have the
option I think related to that is you
know having the option to take the job
is I actually sort of regret not having
a better relationship with like my
professors in the sense that when you
apply for jobs you often need to have
reference letters and to ask for
reference list letters can be a little
bit awkward unless you have a really
good relationships with these professors
and actually know who you are so yeah I
think for the purpose of being prepared
for jobs and these internships I would
say you know don't disregard the needs
to get reference letters and think you
know who are you going to ask these from
you need some people on your side to be
able to get these yeah and you know so
so that's actually the one thing that I
did do right but I think I only did it
right because I knew I was going to do a
master's and I think a lot of people go
to work and then they don't realize
after a few years of work then they
decide oh I want to go back and get a
masters and then they don't have
reference letters so I had known that I
was going to do my masters so I had
really thought about it but there was
someone in my school and my bachelor's
that you know she was smart so he had
like he was top of our class but he had
zero contact with any professors so he
had to just kind of
like knock on their door but because he
had grades they wrote him the letters
but they had to be like can you tell me
something about yourself I I definitely
didn't have any enemies amongst the
professors or anything but I was just I
just very much get to myself sometimes
and also at the end I probably thought
well maybe I should have gone to more of
that person's tutorials and lectures and
yeah I think them and just doing the
problems myself because at the end of
the day I would kind of like a reference
from that person and I don't know it's
it's not a big deal and I got the
reference letters and it was fine but
yeah probably something I had no
intention to do you regret skipping
those bosses not inherently like I
didn't skip them because I was like a
really bad student I just skipped them
because I thought that I could probably
learn better on my own and sometimes
that was the case I did if I just spent
an hour reading the material or the
textbook or whatever I'm working the
problems myself they'll probably be more
productive than me just sitting there in
the lecture like just passively but just
just watching so I don't regret it from
that point of view but it's probably not
a good look like yeah if you want that
professor to grant you a reference later
hmm that's actually one of my regrets I
think I went to class too much and I'm
not saying don't go to class but from my
perspective I'm a visual learner and so
I need to either read the material or do
the problems and like I agree I have to
read it to understand it yeah whereas I
think I've seen so many puppy photos on
Instagram from scrolling through my
phone in class and in hindsight I think
I would have saved myself a lot of time
if in some classes I would have just
done the work on my own yeah that I
guess this is opening up a lot of
thoughts about topic we could talk about
this for ages but I think yeah I had
memories of walking out of like physics
lectures and some random
friend I'd seen in the corridor from
another class would be like ah hey Toby
you like what was that lecture you were
just in and I'd be like I was like
physics and I'd be like why would you
learn I'd be like yeah if I had to spit
in that hour just reading something
relevant I would have had a much better
idea yeah I was doing so I think you
know you can definitely go to all those
lectures that maybe find a balance
between you know still being up-to-date
with the work because I think by the end
I did realize I didn't need to be at the
lectures to learn but I did like going
to them for the sense of connection with
my peers and to like find people to do
the assignments worth and to have a
relationship with the lecturer like
there's lots of other benefits of being
there mm-hmm and also for me I had a
fear of falling behind and then all of a
sudden having like 12 chapters to learn
for an exam so going to the lectures
kind of kept me like okay this is how
much work I have to do before or like
this is your knowledge I need to gain
this week yeah ideally you'd go to all
the lectures and do all the work
yourself but thank you spend time maybe
you have to sacrifice one or the other
yeah alright thank you for sharing your
regret so good for having me and thank
you guys for watching
[Music]